okay gross cave okay broskis we are
doing a cornered rat ok we're doing a
cornered rat let's get to [ __ ] it what
is it there's a sexy woman blocking my
path she is she's so hot though you know
that [ __ ] come out and get around here
there were young oh [ __ ] you [ __ ] oh
great I woke up in a motel you know many
times I've woken up at a motel with like
blood on my hands enough times let me
just say it's enough time so k okay
let's see here and you have give yet
these skills [ __ ] yeah look at
this stupid logic person you know guess
go find a heated rock or something shut
my [ __ ] heads too big there we go
got a minute what did you say something
yeah let's keep this say the rackets
like you goodness I came stove it like
follows your head Ike note ok it's one
thing to say you've got the skills to be
a lot of people looking for him he's
holed up in the rat way Warren's heart
crazy old coot from what I / when it's
in less than touch in the right way
Warren's be careful they're not the only
one looking for him and I find the right
way waters yeah we should I gladness
idea I'm one bad
yeah yeah yeah if you like that are you
here tell Marcel anything I line have
taught me so did I know why they have it
all right all right get down this around
okay there we go so this isn't like hard
to fight this guy how come they can't
find them if you like the skies as a
mentally challenged rat or something
okay I'm gonna eat well climb the [ __ ]
assistive what the [ __ ] was that about
don't do something go away what no
that's not me I'm not desperate oh yes i
can ask that till see how do you still
see how do you this is just a trick to
get they go for the door huh I told you
to go away I told you to go away I'm not
opening this door for anybody and no
doubt you are one of them leave me alone
I told you to go away I am I putting
this door for anybody hey I then feed
really is alive you're gonna come in and
tell me how your family won't you open
the jar batch come in mustn't speak to
me
this'll just take a moment come on I'll
lock into our bench this one always Ella
oh that's a better in torchlight there
we are come come in that's good hey
welcome [ __ ] guy on the door holy [ __ ]
so Delphine keeps up the fights after
all these years I don't even realize
it's hopeless right now I tried to seven
years ago yes yes so you said but so
what haven't you figured it out yet what
more needs to happen Aldwyn has with her
the dragon from the dawn of no one can
escape it he I tried to fit in yes only
a dragon thought come it seems that the
gods an allergy I want then we must go
quickly now take me to tell me much just
thank you for watching y'all